Bộ giáo dục và đặc tạo với công bố bản từng quan sữa điểm các món thi tốt nghiệp Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông
năm 2020 với điểm Trung bình các món học Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông.
Bản năm lớp mời, mời một, mời hai sinh cả nước, ở cả mời hai món học.
Điểm Trung bình thi tốt nghiệp Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông điều thấp hơn điểm Trung bình học Bà của học sinh.
Môn toán, điểm Trung bình tốt nghiệp của thi sinh là bốn về bệm em tám điểm.
Chau khi điểm Trung bình học Bà của học sinh trong bà năng học là mời về không ba điểm.
Điểm thi thấp hơn điểm học bà tới 2020.
Môn tiền Anh, điểm Trung bình thi tốt nghiệp Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông cũng thấp hơn điểm học Bà của học sinh
1 phẩy năm mời bệm điểm.
Trong nhiều năm qua, Bộ giáo dục và đào tạo thực hiện đôi sáng điểm thi tốt nghiệp Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông
của thi sinh với điểm học bà nhằm định dựng khách quan.
Toàn diễn chất lượng dảy và học, đặc biệt là tính thực chất trong đánh giá cái quả học tập ở nhà triệu phổ thông.
Theo Bộ giáo dục và đào tạo, chứ hợp có sự dụng cái quả học Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông để tiền sinh.
Các có sự đào tạo cân cử sổ liệu thông kê về tương quan giữa điểm các món thi tốt nghiệp Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông
năm 2020, bởi điểm Trung bình các món học Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông để xế dựng và công bộ quy đổi tương đương điểm Trung bình.
Ngưỡng đầu vào chất từ chương trình, ngành nhóm nàyn hoặc lĩnh tục đào tạo.